legendary comedian Don Rickles has died  at age 90 I've always been you know I  what those days was called outrageous  you know yeah but again as I said  tonight I've never been mean spirited  and it took me a long way and I always  said to young people be different and be  different cost me a lot of rejection but  it paid off in the end the famed insult  comic passed away at his Los Angeles  home Thursday morning as a result of  kidney failure celebs immediately began  sharing their outpouring of love and  grief jimmy kimmel sharing a photo with  Don and John Stamos purchase it he's the  highlight of my life I love this man so  much Don garnered attention starting in  the 60s as a frequent guest on  late-night shows like The Tonight Show  with Johnny Carson oh  I don't hand you're gonna run huh and  the whole crew went  [Applause]  [Music]